okay okay here we go
oh
the people's champ pasha biceps had his
first bout over the weekend and let me
just say it was everything we hoped it
would be
it was [__] hype esports got its
first celebrity mma match when pasha
faced off against mihao ofcha of chazik
a polish fitness influencer and an
absolute beast of a man everyone thought
it was going to be an even match but boy
were we wrong pasha dominated from start
to finish even finishing the bout with a
second round tko with a couple of clean
headshots to the deal everyone in
esports was hyped up from players to
casters everyone was popping off now we
have to ask what's next for pasha and uh
yeah it's not me i'm gonna stick to like
vr boxing